dunder mifflin this is pam pam it's
michael help me i need help right now
michael what's wrong i'm hurt i have
hurt myself
oh my god okay wait wait wait wait wait
this is not looking
good michael do you need me to call an
ambulance no i want you to pick me up
okay wait a second i thought you said
that you were hurt i am hurt
i want to come to work but i need you to
come and pick me up
no god hey whoa michael oh god
it's okay it's jim just say again really
loudly
uh what happened okay i burned my foot
very badly on my foreman grill and i now
need someone to come and bring me into
work
you burned your foot on a foreman grill
i enjoy having breakfast in bed i like
waking up to the smell of bacon sue me
and since i don't have a butler i have
to do it myself
so most nights before i go to bed i will
lay six strips of bacon out on my george
foreman grill
then i go to sleep when i wake up i plug
in the grill
i go back to sleep again then i wake up
to the smell of crackling bacon it is
delicious it's good for me
it's perfect way to start the day today
i got up
i stepped onto the grill and i clamped
down on my foot that's it
i don't see what's so hard to believe
about that
do you want to know how i actually hurt
my wrist
yes i was hula hooping kevin and i
attended class for fitness and for fun
oh my god i've mastered all the moves
the pizza toss the tornado
the scorpion the oopsie doodle why are
you telling me this
because no one will ever believe you
no no
you sick son of a [ __ ]
hey cuz i heard you're having money
problems
no you didn't listen i got the answer
you declare bankruptcy
all your problems go away how would that
help creed
in monopoly you go bankrupt you lose you
don't go by monopoly man
that game is nuts nobody just picks up
get out of jail free cards
those things cost thousands that is a
good point
bankruptcy michael is nature's do-over
it's a fresh start it's a clean slate
like the witness protection program
not at all i've always wanted to be in
the witness protection program
fresh start no debts no baggage i've
already got my name picked out
lord rupert everton i'm a uh
a shipping merchant who raises fancy
dogs
that's a life
i declare
bankruptcy it's 9 a.m
why is no one working amy santiago is a
few minutes late and we're all trying to
guess why
i like to play i'd say she's
in line at the bank
this is fun it is fun but you're all
wrong
she clearly slipped through a subway
grade and is having terrible sex with a
mole man
there she is amy where have you been
we've been worried sick do you care to
explain yourself
i'm just 70 seconds late it's not a big
deal don't worry about it santiago you
will tell us and you will
tell us now there's a problem at the
bank
hot damn yes it is true
i michael scott am signing up with an
online dating service
thousands of people have done it and i
am going to do it
i need a username and i have a great one
little kid lover that way people will
know exactly where my priorities are at
jackpot let's do this and how am i
supposed to get all the way up there
gracefully boost my bottom i'm boosting
boost my bottom
phil recruited me to sell these cards
and now i am recruiting you
who is this guy again don't worry about
phil he drives a corvette he is doing
just fine
okay calling cards are
the wave of the future these things sell
themselves who uses calling cards anyway
you know what
that's a nice attitude ryan i'm just
helping you invest in your future my
friend
it sounds like a get-rich-quick scheme
yes thank you you will get rich quick we
all will
can you lose a lot of money on that
other investment the one from the email
you know what toby when the son of the
deposed king of nigeria emails you
directly asking for help you help his
father ran the freaking country
okay all right so
raise your hand if you want to get rich
all right no um how is this not a
pyramid scheme
all right let me explain it again
phil has recruited me and another guy
now we are getting three
people each the more people that get
involved the more people who are
investing the more money we're all gonna
make it's not a pyramid scheme it is a
it's not even a scheme per se it's
i have to go make a call the math thing
isn't the problem night shift's keeping
you and kevin apart
you two just need a bone what did you
say don't say it again
i said you two need a bone wow
dare you detective diaz i am your
superior officer bone what happens in my
bedroom detective
is none of your business bone
don't ever speak to me like that again
why did you do that dude just pen up now
he knows problem solved
no god no
god please no no no
i've never been more proud of you for
anything in your life i mean
i've solved a lot of cases for you and
yet crime is continued
on test kit okay i'll be putting them
everywhere and
please don't throw these out this is a
radon test kit
please don't throw these out see them
all over the office
toby has been leaving radon kits
everywhere like he owns the place
the first time i threw mine away i
thought it was an ant trap
but i figured i'd rather live with anson
with his creepy little disc
the second time i thought it was one of
those
you know the things you turn over and a
moose like a cow thing
but upon closer examination it was
another ant trap so i threw it away and
the third time
i did it out of spite
come on michael you're you're
interrupting you're kidding me god
you say rayon is silent but deadly and
then you expect me not to make farting
noises with my mouth
what is this i sit down you know what
we're not gonna die of radon we're gonna
die of boredom
yeah right and if i had a gun
with two bullets and i was in a room
with hitler bin laden and toby i would
shoot toby twice
no that's not okay you're all right
really funny
and then you went too far i would kill
bin laden and then toby
no that's still okay geniuses how would
you do it
sergeant i'd like you to meet richard
and
dan they are puppies very cute sir
maybe your twins would like some little
furry friends
i'm sorry sir but that's impossible with
the twins learning how to walk chaos
reigns at the jeffers household
i can't let those innocent pups into
that mad house terry won't do you like
that
i understand just know you have
disappointed
all three of us that's cold sir
what's wrong michael it's like a gum in
my ear
you do this just stinks don't touch it
please don't touch it
you got a ton of dandruff okay let me be
how did you get gum in your hair i was
walking in and i noticed something shiny
under stanley's car and i got under to
see
what it was and i messed up my hair
all for a stupid piece of tin foil but
best case scenario
you thought it was a quarter kill me
right now we have peanut butter in the
kitchen
i don't feel like peanut butter give me
an ice cream sandwich nope not for you
it's for your hair and it is
9 a.m no dwight not the good peanut
butter people are gonna get mad hey hey
hey this is my hair we're talking about
smells good tastes good too
oh donald that's disgusting wow a lot of
calories
well just don't leave it on too long
keep massaging please
i'm tired of politics let's get that
punk
blood so this is amazing of course we
have no idea where he is but i love
where your head's at he has no family
maybe there was a girlfriend or someone
he worked with at the coffee shop the
coffee shop
why would someone who knows they have 21
million dollars coming take a minimum
wage job
because he needed access to that
building because that's where the
money's hidden
all right we got to get there quick
maybe we should take the chopper
here's that chopper deathblade
sidewinder
it's go time roger that wet blanket no
from now on call me
velvet thunder
you